Tracie's with us in Richmond Virginia hi
Tracy how are you
hi babe how are you better than I
deserve what's up my husband and I have
two kids and we are trying to figure out
what we just found out that we are
pregnant with twins yeah so we're super
excited number three number four number
three number four yes sir so we started
financial peace back in January my
mother my mom and dad gave it to us for
Christmas and we started out at 35,000
in debt and we are at 18 no 16,000 now
so we're on a roll we feel like we're
doing really good but I am having a hard
time with whether or not we should stay
at home or whether or not I should quit
my job and stay at home what do you make
I make 30,000 what's he make 70 okay
daycare with four kids you know am I
going to turn after 30 no you're not and
that's what that's where we're kind of
thinking but yeah I just I wasn't sure
if I should try the desire is to stay
home I would love to stay at home and my
husband would like for me to stay home
too but I just feel like there's this
opportunity of growth and my and my job
as well and I just I'm torn well I mean
the question first and foremost is what
does Tracy want to do the second
question is can we afford to do it okay
and if RACI wants to stay home with the
four kids then let's start working
towards what have we got to do to make
that happen so the twins are going to be
delivered when we're thinking around
Thanksgiving okay all right and how much
progress on the remaining 16,000 if you
guys go bananas can you make on that
between now and Thanksgiving I think
we're going to be able to have it paid
off by by Christmas okay and that's that
so you're debt-free and you have a 70 if
you come home you're dead free with the
$70,000 income right yes yes and we need
to build the emergency fund up and then
we need to start investing
and moving on run your budget out as if
you were living only on his check coming
home and look at a budget or to a foe a
pretend budget a trial budget right as
if that was happening today
not counting the sixteen thousand
dollars in debt because it'll be gone
but run your budget out and get
comfortable with that I think you're
coming home because I think you want to
and I think you're gonna be able to
afford to because of what you've done in
the last year paying off all this debt
and you've learned how to handle the
money and make it behave congratulations
[Music]